I follow you not in a creepy way but in
a journalistic way I follow your
Instagram I follow you on social media
you took a picture you were in London I
think and you saw a giant inflatable
Jeff Goldblum statue I did and no one
was supposed to touch it you charged it
and lepton it even though security tried
to stop you I think we have a photograph
right here take a look at that and you
can see that security that yellow arm is
a security guy trying to get underneath
the rope to stop you now explain your
actions Bree I don't know why I have to
explain that I heard that there was a
giant statue of Jeff Goldblum under a
bridge I immediately went there and
tried to climb on top of it
right that's just what one does yes
there were ropes around it I don't know
why it was there it blew my mind
and I just the chest thing and the
lounging and I was just drawn to it I
just I had to climb it yeah get in there
yeah and get your hands on that Jeff
Goldblum torso yeah I just couldn't help
myself
yeah that's cool and you were there
repercussions did you get arrested or
anything no I know there was a there was
security people there but you know
what's London so they were really polite
I mean they weren't I didn't know that
about London security all right right
through you go yeah they were like
they're actually what they said to me
was you're not special miss you are not
special and I was like I'm not because
I'm on top of this statue and I don't
see anybody else
[Laughter]
[Applause]
man I am asking you know you also I
noticed that you you flicked a photo
bomb other celebrities when they're
getting their picture taken there's this
paparazzi picture of Hugh Jackman and I
think we have it here and if you look in
the background here you're just there
eating were you trying to be in the
photo or were you okay i straight-up did
not ask to be in that photograph I was
eating at a mamey by myself minding my
own business and all of a sudden
yeah the sudden there were all these
people and taking pictures and flashes
and I was like why are all these people
here and then I was like oh Hugh Jackman
is just standing right in front of me
thanks a lot I was just having dinner I
wasn't trying to get you tell you
Jackman you're not special no no I just
kept like creepily like eating edamame
and like sucking on edamame pods yet
you're doing in the picture you're doing
absolutely very very little to draw
attention to yourself I'm doing I don't
I didn't I don't ask for this but you do
sometimes I saw a picture that someone
took a picture of Jessica Alba at a
Lakers game look at you in the
background you're definitely trying to
call intentionally trying to get in on
that action I don't even remember that
picture being taken I that's just my
natural face at a basketball game really
basketball games terrifying so god
Dwyane Wade scares the [ __ ] out of me if
I'm close to a basketball game I freaked
out we freaked out but yeah I go into a
weird I don't know it's scary the balls
going in there and
they're moving so fast in a basketball
I've ever heard in my life